hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong it's your girl
jacqueline alongside my lovely and
talented co-host mr mark ellis
jacqueline uh hey um i don't know if you
saw this um a couple days ago but did
you know that the oscar nominations were
announced
i you know
i think i did see something about that
on my calendar okay i just have one
question i know you've been you you've
been you've been inundated in this i
just can i ask you one question about
the nominations but i have to get off my
chest okay
why is licorice pizza a harder movie to
make than dune
those those nominations were so chaotic
like denny vineyard literally like
put the entire desert and and frank
herbert's movie on his back and made it
watchable
after the first one and he couldn't even
score a director nomination and he is
like the susan lucci of best director
poor guy just poor man we need to rule
this incredible
paul thompson
should only be able to make a movie once
every five years so other directors can
get a shot at getting nominated because
look i'm sure the guy's movies are great
but he just takes a bunch of famous
people puts him on a street corner in
tarzana there's your movie then he build
a new creative like a whole world and
the guy can't get a sniff at the oscars
come on they like pta man and as
somebody who is like the hugest i look
um the man can make phantom thread which
is basically a love letter to you know
seamstresses and he can make a porno
movie i'm sorry the man has range give
him
his credit okay he made boogie nights
come on i'll give paul anderson credit
for making mortal kombat
upon all those oscars
listen well you know what paul anderson
probably is the guy who thinks that our
director today is his version of pta
because folks we're talking about
transformers that's right the 58
rotten 85 audience score film that
spawned a franchise that some people
wish was better than pet cemetery shout
out to eric barber who said that megan
fox was his 15 year old love and he was
the one that gave us uh this sort of
recommendation to do this one today i'm
looking forward to this one today if
nothing else because of our guests that
we have today we've enjoyed them
individually but now we have them as the
duo they will always meant to be that's
right jay washington and winston and
marshall from blurt in the hood are here
gentlemen how y'all doing i'm still i
mean for another 72. i was gonna say
unfortunately we have had to do what
like two going on now three and four
projects today for the last 20 foe i
just i am tired of him you know how you
look you know how you love your mama but
you wish you could just like go to the
other side of the house and she would
just leave you alone for an extended
period of time that's that's just really
what's going on right here's like this
little brother that you just can't get
off your back you're like hey man let me
live my life and he won't let you live
his life he's like that bald creepy
uncle with the scars like you know that
that loves to bring himself
that loves to bring stuff up
that we're interviewing a band on their
comeback tour where they don't really
want to
be around each other except for when
they're on stage like they have
blurred in the hood behind the music
this is very bad
um but the one thing is great about
having both of you here even though it
might be a bit of a marital counseling
session is the fact that we're going to
be talking about a film that both of you
feel very passionate about we have
invited mark into our little negro
spiritual today this is our version of
black history month
the truth
i'm glad he made he got the invite not
to the cookout this is more of like a
little tip
so we'll see how he fares by the end of
it is there a wristband i need to wear
in case anybody asks me what i'm doing
here like just be like i belong i was
invited yeah it would actually say
sounds of blackness i believe on it it's
from the 90s what's the name of the
sounds of blackness
i believe yeah
i mean
i think we can if we can get mark the
drip of the
the um the bengals quarterback if we can
get him a little bit of that drip
yeah a little
drip that'll be all right um but hey
look this group obviously has opinions
about this
i think i may be the only one that's
actually a fan of this series or at
least of the transformers movies but
like who which one of y'all is the
biggest transformers fan not the movies
but like
fan of who they are and what they do
that would be me because i'm actually
older i have more experience and i've
experienced more life and i actually
have more fun in my life as opposed to
my co-host that creepy uncle who's
always trying to what up you that's
that's i wasn't
he's a sheltered child so this is what
happens you have to tell winston about
something now and he'd be like oh my god
i never saw that black movies fences but
like i just recently re-watched the
whole transformer series g1 on like all
the different things that's available to
be all them we've watched the original
movie you know the animated movie so
like i've always loved this so when they
said that they were doing a live action
movie i was like yes let's do this and
then i saw it and i was like i want to
fight people just because
you just want to fight people just
because because i was so angry i was so
angry i was just like this don't make no
sense creepy uncle with conspiracy
theories about how people try to ruin
his childhood so he wants to fight them
for no reason like i tried to warn y'all
at the start of this show
this boy get a haircut two weeks ago and
he's still gonna keep talking okay oh my
lord
um
i mean i i guess that we're gonna go
ahead and say you jay um
did you gentlemen own toys did y'all
have them mm-hmm what you mean i did i
was about to order one two days ago off
ebay
i saw a pretty king i was like i need
dude
well the the real question though is did
you own toys at a time in your life when
it was still considered acceptable to
open the toys and actually play with
them yeah because that's those are the
transformers that i grew up with and so
the 86 animated movie i'll never forget
my dad took the day off work took me and
my brother to go see it and the movie
traumatized a lot of folks because
optimus prime eats it but
it didn't bother me and my brother
nearly as much as it bothered my dad
because we were like upset and so we're
leaving the theater my dad's like we
took off work so i could take the kids
to the movie
what kind of world are we living
i mean you know i i i
haven't seen the og movie
uh but i've watched all the og cartoon
uh because they that's what they would
do is they would give you the new new
saturday morning cartoon like the sonic
the hedgehogs the reboots but they would
plug in some stuff that had already
wrapped up so they would throw in the
transformers but my favorite by far was
beast wars i was hoping we were going to
move towards beast wars as these films
went on and then i started watching the
films and i was like let's move away
from beast wars let's not also ruin my
childhood like apparently the og movie
did mark ellis and his brother
yeah i mean look so uh i it's so funny
i'm feeling i already know but i'm gonna
go ahead and start this way j
sir is rotten tomatoes wrong about
transformers really quickly nope not at
all not no it should actually be lower
let's keep going all right keep moving
winston sir come on no no they're not
wrong 58 is like a good number uh i i
like that i mean you could go with the
straight fitty fitty if you want but
58's perfect where it's at we don't need
to move from there
ah mr mark ellis please help me um i'll
say that 58 is
i can get this movie to fresh because if
we're talking about the first michael
bay transformers movie that launched
this insane franchise that made a lot of
really bad movies just this first one on
its ear is not a terrible film
especially when you compare it to the
other sort of toys like you know dudes
saying i grew up with this movies that
were coming out around that time it's
nowhere near as good as what the
audience score would suggest it's
nowhere near 85 percent but i can get
this movie to fresh jacqueline just the
first one
it's just the first one uh i can
definitely get this movie to fresh i
would put it just shy of 30 certified
fresh it is problematic boots down i'm
not going to pretend it
i love this movie and rotten tomatoes is
hella wrong and it is its ugly cousin
steps children is the reason why this
one which is greatness has been drugged
down
because this film was fresh and i will
tell the tale because when i started at
rotten tomatoes this film set at 63 on
the tomato meter and it is progressively
through these various iterations and as
more people begin to despise michael bay
and do like re-watches of his entire
body of work that is bringing down our
average it's not fair it started as
fresh i just want everyone to know that
so rotten tomatoes is wrong and how am i
going to be the voice of reason and
fandom in this conversation i got you
back jaclyn oh no no no no oscar's girl
that's going to be this person today
okay jacqueline jacqueline we
both
speak from a fandom point of view which
is part of the reason why
this movie needs to be rotten don't play
these games
let me tell you something the fact he
didn't you never said you had megatron
couldn't be a gun megatron was always a
gun listen
listen
the three-time oscar-nominated
millions at the box office genius that
is this original transformers i will not
allow this aggression to stand but make
sure you mention what it's nominated for
mention what it's nominated for don't
you do this like the greatest best
picture ever listen listen
let's go ahead
and get mark please before we get into
y'all getting on your snowboxer can you
please give me the synopsis of
transformers so we know exactly what
food we are about to eat i would be
happy to jacqueline for no other reason
because this allows us all to put up our
blinders to your revenge of the fallens
to your dark of the moons to your the
last nights and just focus on this one
movie this one film that features the
wit wikis and yes i didn't open with
robots because the movie kind of prefers
humans over robots which is a point of
contention for sure but the whit wikis
are sam who was played by shia labeouf
and he's got a great great granddaddy
who was one of the first explorers to
the arctic and wouldn't you know it
archie his
great great grandpa found a thing called
an all spark or at least a robot that
wanted to find the all spark and what
the allspark is is a all-powerful device
that both the autobots and the
decepticons who are the two factions of
transformers are desperately searching
for the decepticons want the allspark
because they want to rule the galaxy
with an iron fist the autobots want it
because they want to help maintain peace
so basically the allspark is like if
your preferred political party has the
house and the senate and the presidency
it's like you get to do everything you
want so we're both looking for this
thing and now because samwit wiki's
related to the guy who once upon a time
discovered some robot stuff now all the
robots are searching for him in modern
day and we have to hide the robots from
sight because they don't want to be seen
by humans but they also have to work
with sam who happens to have one of the
autobots driving him and megan fox
around town that's bumblebee so we have
optimus we have megatron we have
bumblebee we have a lot of great
transformers popping into this movie and
a whole
lot of humans and a lot of jokes there's
a lot of comic relief from this movie
and as a comedian i will say it is those
jokes that take this movie from a super
fresh film down to just smelling some
rottenness but i still have your back
you and i can be the autobots today
they're not
i love mark's synopsis of this movie
because this literally sounds like what
a drunk a drunk frat bro at a bar would
tell you like yo tell me about
transformers dude listen it's robots
right and so this is all spark they
don't know what it is it's just that
it's all about the decepticons that was
the literal description of this movie
and it was perfectly on point like
[Music]
listen there's a lot to be said
specifically about ratchet and jazz
listen yes oh my god
there's a lot to be said about this
movie not even going to pretend that all
of it is going
but
before we get into all that let's go
ahead and toss it over to tim ryan for
two minutes with tim so he can let us
know what the critics thought of ratchet
and jazz because i'm sure they had
thoughts
[Music]
the transformers movies are among the
most critically maligned of all the
big-budget franchises but things started
out on reasonably solid footing in 2007.
sure a lot of critics derided the thin
script and were divided over whether the
action scenes were loud and exciting or
simply loud but there was also more than
a little praise for the cast which
included up-and-comers shia labeouf
megan fox and josh duamal transformers
is rotten but at 58 with 227 reviews and
it does have an 85 audience score and
here's a super quick rundown on the
other movies in the franchise
transformers revenge of the fallen is
rotten at 20
transformers dark of the moon is rotten
at 35
transformers age of extinction is rotten
at 17
transformers last night is rotten at 15
and the spinoff bumblebee
is certified fresh at 90 percent but
what did the critics have to say about
transformers back in 2007 in a rotten
review tom charity of cnn.com wrote the
illusion is shattered whenever the bots
start talking or the action stops
director michael bay tries to gloss over
the infantile plot but it would take a
lighter wittier touch to square the
movie's pedestrian script however in a
fresh review richard roper of ebert and
roper said it's a big cool dopey noisy
non-stop action powerhouse it's also too
long by a half hour and it left my ears
ringing but it's a lot of fun the rotten
tomatoes critic's consensus reads while
believable characters are hard to come
by in transformers the effects are
staggering and the action is
exhilarating so that's transformers
let's kick it back to jaclyn and mark
who are more than meets the eye but are
not robots in disguise at least as far
as i know anyway i haven't seen him in a
while back to you folks
[Laughter]
oh he hasn't seen my new animatronic arm
it's beautiful it wears you and you wear
it
i'm just kidding no sorry tim i have not
developed uh autobot capabilities in in
the in the pandemic but
let's go ahead and break down this movie
ladies and gentlemen i'm going to fight
the good fight for the transformers so
ryan keep the music
[Music]
all right winston listen
i know but what was the scene that made
you be like cause i know when you first
saw this like well first of all when did
you first see this but i'm sure when you
first saw this you were going into it
hopeful i would hope i don't know break
it down for me i mean you're talking 0.7
so i'm in the middle of college i want
to say this came out summer 07 so i you
know just finished my freshman year uh
you know excited about transformers i
feel like i took a date to go see
transformers and then i was embarrassed
i took a date to go see transformers
just in the sense that i thought some of
the designs were kind of wack i i
remember the transformers being like
like hella robots on hella robots and we
got a like kind of a standard basketball
five-on-five lineup i don't remember
seeing this many humans that i had to
interact with like it was always just
the one or two kids that were hanging
out with them not an entire army um and
anthony anderson like i wasn't really
ready for all of that and i understand
that we kind of jack into movies through
people that we can relate to so i don't
have a problem with having sam witwicky
and kind of having like he's trying to
impress a girl type scenario i think
that's a lot of fun stuff like that but
i feel like you really got away from
what made transformers great his robots
this guy's vehicles
you know kind of doing the dang thing we
spent a lot of time with conspiracy
theorists and parents being drunk and
talking about earthquakes and then
masturbation like i don't
it just it was too much we weren't
focused on why we were here at megatron
two some hours into the film come on man
okay uh mr mark ellis sir when did you
was this a shmoes no watch ironically
transformers was not a schmoe's no
review because we hadn't started the
show yet but that's kind of the thing
that the christian and i were like
hanging out at comedy clubs and like
kind of talking about transformers this
movie coming out so we saw the movie
together
and i don't know if jay was with us
because jay and i were kind of ships
passing in the night around that time
like we'd see each other at the laugh
factory or like the comedy union or
something like that
and so it was like eight comics all went
to go see transformers because we were
all those prototypical like boys who
grew up playing with transformers so we
want to go see this movie we're super
excited and i will say that i agree with
winston's point that once you continue
to get muddled down in the humanity of
this movie it does lose its steam and so
i was loving this movie
for a good i don't know 45 minutes and
and the comic relief was working for me
for a while if you want to say that the
comic relief is the parents or it's
anthony anderson or it's john turtur or
whoever it is it's like great they can
be the comic relief but when you put all
of them into one movie together it sort
of takes away from the fun of the robots
in disguise which is again why i'm
paying to see the movie because the name
of the movie is not a bunch of open
micros running jokes the name of the
movie is transformers and so i want to
see more of that but
the other point i'll make to jaclyn's
defense is that i do think this movie's
fresh because
wow do those robots look awesome the
special effects still hold up and a
great example of that is when we first
get the reveal of optimus prime in his
full glory and he's looking down and it
and it's the voice and you just hear the
power and the leadership emanating from
this
pickup this semi rig and it's like wow
this is the movie i came to see so
there's enough of those moments jaclyn
to get me to fresh with this movie
that's fair uh jay do you have a moment
in which you lost it or better yet let
me ask you this is there a moment in the
film that you're like okay it's stupid
but i like this
well tyrese
[Laughter]
what are you serious like i need a
credit card
for your wallet pocket
bucket my back pocket
do that back walking left cheek left
cheek left finger
between that and then also again uh that
i will agree real quick the the visual
effects when you first see
the very first decepticon that comes on
the base and the first time you see him
transform you're like okay this is dope
but then you start hearing the names and
that's what made me mad because
scorpenoc is not a little scorpion that
comes out of somebody's back
devastator is not a bulldozer you know
i'm saying like what is happening and so
it started losing me and again i'm with
winston you only gave me
five on five like a basketball team this
movie is about a race of robots if you
watch the first episode of the regular
transformers cartoon it is 18 autobots
sitting there next to teletrain one you
get five and i gotta hear optimus prime
tell me my bad at these steps on some
flowers i was done i was done when i was
where i said my bad i was like what what
they watched tv oh yeah that's how you
learn yeah how do we learn your world
wide web
color is absolutely what those kids
watched i know it was like why are y'all
acting simple i know that's what they
watched i know that's what they watch
and y'all are just being obtuse right
now that is no personality was based on
homie the clown
that's what jazz was based on
that makes sense you know mom wanted me
to ground you you're three minutes late
right oh well just another thing you did
for me dad because you're such a swell
guy one more thing all right i love you
sleep good handsome man
what are you doing what are you doing no
watch the path what's bad
please please please
sorry my bad oh my god
you could you couldn't wait for fun you
could wait for five minutes just each
day just stay but even that stuff
even that stuff just gets so much worse
as the movies progress and so this one
was sort of like a gateway drug to to
all of that but again like my biggest
problem jaclyn with the first movie was
was just all of these different comic
reliefs like coming together as one and
it's like that just to me felt
overbloated in the wrong way if this
movie was overbloated with too many
robots fighting each other i'd be like
well it's what i paid to see but i just
felt like i was maybe sold on a slightly
different movie i mean
i think i this is one of the reasons why
i like this one is i didn't have the
emotional connection to transformers
that other kids did i didn't watch i
didn't have the toys or whatever i like
transformers but it was not in that like
because that was just back in the day
where like transformers came on gi joe
transformers and then it would gem
my little pony and that was me i was
like the boys can do what they got to do
for the first hour of back to school i'm
gonna kick that second hour with jim and
my little pony and like that was like
the divide back then and that was you
know that's why it's kind of crappy now
that you know they still make those
divides with young kids interests and
toys because that's like why the i would
say there's a lot more young men that
are into transformers and there's a lot
more women that this movie may have been
the first thing we did so it was smart i
do think it was smart for them to add
more people to it winston you went on
that date trust me she said yes because
she thought the idea that trailer was
better
if they would have made the transform
movies that you wanted to go she she
wouldn't have went with you she went
cause he was light skinned with a baby
face have you seen him without his
mustache and beard she was a light
skinned dude that was baby face
it's one of those things that like
because a i could have always taken her
to something like knocked up it was it
was that kind of summer and you know
there's a lot of really great films out
there
i think what got me is again i don't
have a problem with the love story i
don't have a problem with like again
there were always the teenagers kind of
hanging out with the transformers to be
like okay well we'll help you out
however we can optimus like that's that
is kind of standard i'm here for that
that's totally fine i think what my
problem just became is once again
the actors that play
shia labeouf's parents are actually very
funny anthony anderson i think is
hysterical it's that like mark said
you're getting too many voices i don't
need 20 comic reliefs i don't need to
spend time talking about the dog's pain
pills and like you on drugs kid huh you
want drugs you want my gun go for my gun
go on come on take it like i i didn't
know what movie i actually came here to
watch is kind of the problem um and when
you throw that in with the fact that
starscream is probably one of my
favorite transformers and they made him
look like some reject geometric shape
yeah like that that got thrown with the
little chrome chrome on him
come on man
but okay remove for what you thought
you don't think that in its abstract
that's still a cool design are you just
saying the design is not what you expect
it's still that's the thing i liked the
design of the other transformers i
personally just did not like his design
i thought that he was too just geometric
and and i know that you have the wings
on him from the og cartoon and whatnot
but there was still something cool
looking about him
i i literally felt like i was watching a
a new flavor of dorito trip like fly out
and attack people like it was just very
weird for me
so mark you like the cgi for sure and
yes it was sound design and visual
effects that it was nominated for
sir mr jackson so
some of the coolest sound effects and
they get so many different sort of
electronic voices but also some humans
doing those voices i think at least in
the sequels the lead singer faith no
more mike patton is actually making some
of those like electronic noises with his
mouth it's like it's really cool when
you see the behind-the-scenes stuff on
it so yes all of that and i will always
apologize for anthony anderson in this
movie why because he supports the
washington football team who's now the
washington commanders he's wearing a
clinton portis jersey he's got his keys
in a necklace that is washington so i
will root for anthony anderson in this
movie and john turtur is such a great
actor that it upsets me that when he
shows up it's just like another comedic
force but jacqueline like watching this
movie
shiloh both really doesn't do it for me
in this film because he's just his
paranoia or his nerves or whatever i
understand feeling like that in high
school especially around someone who is
like megan fox but it was it was almost
too much for me to make him the lead
character because he's so jittery and
just so like he he drank 19 baja blasts
right before he was using every scene
and he's just like so
like there are
robots the size of houses running around
what do you want him to be calm cool and
collected
he calls the police when bumblebee
drives off on his own he and he chases
bumblebee on a bike like my cars are
stolen you're like bro for real for real
this is what we're gonna do you just
can't you gonna chase the car i'm
following i'm in pursuit again there's
certain things that just get too much
it's like it's no longer believable
about it no i'm right there with you and
mark you do have a point he did have too
much baja blast while trying to play
xbox with turned two robots which
driving his chevrolet while someone else
drove a gmc while someone else was
dealing with coca-cola like i i yeah
there was a lot of stuff going on there
nokia you know was out here
time out though let me tell you about
what i think is one of the coolest
moments really quickly first of all when
megan is like sitting on
shya's lap it's like well the car drives
and she's just like well if he can
change into anything why does he change
into this beat up car and then they go
on the wheels and it becomes the cool
camaro and the music plays as it pulls
up and he's just like are you gonna get
in the car come on son you know what i
don't understand
why if he's supposed to be like this
super advanced robot does he transform
back into this piece of crap come here
oh see no no that doesn't work
see
right now
see
[Applause]
fantastic
now you pissed him off
that car is sensitive i mean four
thousand dollars just drove off
[Applause]
they're like yes this is exactly why i'm
taking you to this date movie that is so
sweet yeah
listen as a girl that love lives for
american muscle my very first car was a
dodge challenger and like dream of that
that was the coolest moment in the world
and i will have to admit i'm a huge fan
of american muscle cars so the fact that
it was camaro yeah i'm down like the car
wins already just for that fact and it
should have stayed the 70s version i
also say this one thing too we need to
we need to acknowledge
the late great legend and icon yes that
is in this movie yeah for
five minutes
yeah hey man go get your comments
out baby
dad was so funny
um on the car situation i remember that
like lack of car situation i got my like
got my car i got a car very late in the
in texas if you don't have a car by 15
you're behind yeah you're
you're
right
out of the house before my mom finally
let me drive around the block it was bad
it was so bad looks like i think if i
didn't go to school 10 hours away she
wouldn't have even tried but let's talk
a little bit about shia because he does
get a bad rap in these movies but i
don't think it's shy's fault look chad's
got a lot of fault but we know the kid
can act we know it's in his capability
he's been in performances he's been in
roles where people can know that he acts
i think michael bay said crackhead
dialed up to four
it's not a ten but it's definitely four
level crackhead like you know
i think i think with someone who
like once you see the breadth of shia
labeouf's talent past transformers then
you see you can look back and say okay
this might have been the director who
again by this point in his career
michael bay had made gigantic movies he
had the rock he had armageddon which
there's a funny nod to him again in this
movie he did pearl harbor he'd done bad
boys he had done a lot of things and he
had that reputation by this point too of
being sort of an onsen onset tyrant so
if you are shy with both and you're just
this is your first huge blockbuster
you're coming off like what disturbia
and the the the project greenlight movie
you're like okay i'm just gonna play
with what whatever this guy gives me and
so i understand him and megan fox just
kind of being good soldiers and and also
say i thought megan fox is great in this
movie despite the fact that michael bay
thought he was making a cisco video with
her i think it's really nice that they
are
giving her the role of being like a
gearhead yeah
at least they wrote that character with
a little bit more than just the object
of affection they filmed her like an
object of affection fo sure oh more than
me every time you saw her girl and i i
mean look hey look i remember at the
time being like oh my gosh she's so
pretty well no and and and and i also
feel that like while i do like you said
appreciate they at least gave her
something with a little more depth like
her record and and being a gearhead and
all that kind of stuff that also was
just a smoke screen to then as well as
the uh the other actress to be the the
the hacker rachel that rachel taylor
exactly excuse me rachel taylor but then
that was a smoke screen so that you
could have a transformer jump over one
woman just like no
like like there's a lot of that
happening where it's kind of like um
i think you did all the rest of this so
you can do that you have that one moment
yeah yeah you had to
grab
michael
yeah if you'd look at this cast and say
okay who am i who am i drafting from
this movie to start on my team to
competently handle the scenario that's
playing out with all these machines
crashing on earth megan fox and rachel
taylor might be my first two draft picks
simply because they have cool heads
throughout this movie they're more
level-headed and they're just about
getting the mission done oh
john voight because we found out how he
really feels afterwards and you're like
yep there's checks this checks you found
out how he was and you were like you
know what being a secretary of defense
was like this this is a natural
emergency and then you're like you hear
a lady like yeah okay everybody
got it
it's a well-known fact that john boyd
had no idea he was in a movie
secretary of defense that was such a
check for john
like in fact i'm i'm gonna go ahead and
assume there was a lot of checks for
this one also the three screenwriters on
this are robert orti alex kurtzman and
john rogers john rogers was the man who
brought us catwoman
uh they were involved in like the star
wars star trek series uh re reboot that
uh but he you know like their producers
turned writers i i will put it to you
that way or writer turned producers so
i'm not surprised that maybe the female
characters are underwritten considering
it is a trifecta oh sorry four person
trifecta writing team and then adding in
michael bay on top of it again
no i don't know if they're the ones on
top of it but michael bay this was his
second highest rated film for a very
long time behind the rock and i think
now
uh
the one with john
krasinski where he plays michael bay
that way we're talking about 13 hours
the greatest action film yeah 14 hours
that is very much michael bay fulfilling
his wish fulfillment of like yeah this
is my last chance of looking as hot as
somebody like john krasinski so let me
make him look cool for this last movie
i i loved 13 hours and i think i loved
it so much in part just because it was
michael bay doing what i enjoyed michael
bay films from the start like the bad
boys and the rock and stuff like that
and
then you you have this angle in this
movie and i'm sure because because
especially winston like this might have
been your movie that our our guy eric
who wanted us to talk about this movie
today where you have that film when
you're a teenager and you see this thing
from your childhood and you also see a
very attractive
many attractive females on screen it's
like that's your that's your sort of
sexual awakening and you're like oh this
is this is it it i was already past that
point because if if you were to pin a
movie you can really tell how i function
relationships by the movies that were
quote my sexual awakening because i got
three i got adventures in babysitting
with elizabeth shu
white men can't jump was rosie perez
okay and i got boomerang with robin
givens those are like the three and and
those are all women that are very uh in
control of their relationships
yes
i'll be honest with you mark
my my sexual awakening is a little more
embarrassing it's the
bathing suit shopping scene from the new
guy
uh with dj claws oh and eddie griffin
and eliza dusku
um
but it is what it is
who the [ __ ] nail that oh my god yeah
i forgot about that movie that was in
that like malibu's most wanted
that's my baby's daddy not my baby daddy
my baby's daddy which you knew i'm like
this is a problem
like y'all ain't even getting the like
culture vulture language right like you
know this is my baby's apostrophe
it was so bad
we haven't talked about them but then we
need to give them their day since we're
talking about culture vultures it's
probably a good thing to go and do
jazz and ratchet
what's up little [ __ ] what's up
hey yo this looks like a good spot to
sit down
you know what's really funny do you want
to know who's the voice of jazz do you
all want to know who this is super uh
darius mccrary girl this
edition
from family matters sold us out for that
role but you know what i hope he got a
good check i'm not gonna blame him for
that i mean he'd get residuals off of
the first one you gotta think about it
you know like i hope he's getting his
his love but i will just tell you
without question i was like why why did
they do this that's the part that the
second time around i was like
they really didn't need this like you
want to talk about what they didn't need
they didn't need that exactly it wasn't
even it wasn't even a voice at first let
us not forget when this mark transformed
he was breakdancing
he break he breaks right onto a car
i see the prophecy here's the other
problem and i know that we're just
talking about this specific movie but we
got to talk about the ripple effect for
some reason they thought that was so
dope they decided to double down
they went to the next movie
they doubled down
like that's so so that that to me adds
to i know we got to focus on the movie
that we physically saw last night at 9
00 p.m to make sure we were ready to rew
you know have to refresh
like but
you are setting us up for failure that's
the pro on top of the fact that the one
black autobot you just go merc and
you're gonna have you're gonna have
megatron rip him in half like it was and
it was really rough
if it felt very like a video on youtube
you're like oh i didn't want to see this
you know what i mean like it very much
felt like like you're feeding through
and somebody like shows them like this
is a murder no
um it very much felt like that he very
much felt like he didn't have to go like
that like he never really didn't have to
go like manchester i could have shot him
he didn't have to just no we're gonna
make sure we get rid of the black one
real quick
i'm tired of all of your culture vulture
ways
we've already talked about john tatura
we've already found rachel taylor
anthony anderson and then also um
uh the late great birdie mac but i have
to give it up for mr patel ravi patel
who plays the customer service operator
first of all if you're going to have to
do a potato jokes they don't know that
is an awful south asian stereotype where
they basically make these folks put on
an affectation there's a great
documentary called the trouble with the
poo that breaks down how problematic and
awful this is
early in his career like this guy had
already done uh or was about to do i
think at this point a sundance film
meet the patels which is the documentary
about his parents he's like a really
incredible filmmaker and actor and
writer and this is the kind of work that
he's trying to get this is a big break
for him but he made the most of that
role because that is still one of the
most memorables we talked about left
cheek but the many ways he's like would
you like to sign up for our service oh
my god man this guy is taking these
10 seconds where he is the butt of the
joke and he is actually making it
interesting he's like i do not care
about you white man and your problems
you know i totally forgot that scene
existed and if i could like do what
topher grace did with a phantom menace
and like release the ellis cut of this
movie yeah i think that might be the
scene i take and it's it's not because
he's not doing his best with what he's
given but it's just such like a
stereotype and it's also like yeah you
like this is this is a military
operation you're talking to william
lennox played by josh dumel and you got
to go through customer service to get to
the pentagon it's awful it's wonderful
but you know what i'm happy for him
because trust me if you don't think that
that dude got an agent and a role and
whatever off of that whatever and then
he gets to go on and be a part of master
of none and i'm just saying just because
that was the role he had to take to then
get to these other heights it doesn't
mean you can't make the most of it i i
don't disagree with that but again what
this was also just another commercial
moment uh so we're going to need a
credit card okay i got a v6 started with
though without laughing about it it is
so weird that on a zoom conversation
with three comedians i have to be the
one that's rooting for comedy over
anything else like there's a problem
here's a problem comedy is not a problem
jack it's when it's just overly used
just in the place of being used like i
get it okay you need to make a call fine
this sounds like a comedic moment but it
didn't need to drag out as long as it
did there's so many never forget when
anthony anderson when the fbi comes to
his career right his cousins
he runs through the glass
[Music]
he would definitely not jump in the pool
that is absolutely true that was written
by a white man we all know that like let
me get away from these flying bullets by
jumping in water but jump in a pool oh
no no hold on hold on y'all are
misremembering come on now he he read he
was so scared that they thought he had
drugs he ran through a a glass
door and then he gets tackled into the
pool he goes wait wait wait wait wait
and the fbi just completely takes him
out uh oh then he gotta get the innocent
yelling about his grandmamma what this
is the most white oh my god
accurate that was anthony's line that
was not a line written by alex or anyone
else that was anthony
eating the donuts because they're like
hey let's get this funny chubby guy and
make sure that he eats all the donuts
and so what i i'm going to try to
encapsulate this for for jacqueline who
does not make a living telling jokes on
stage because she's way more too
talented for that
here's the issue with this movie here's
what takes this movie from like a 90
fresh for me seeing all the cool
transformers down to like borderline
rotten is because if you see and jake
can particularly
you know kind of back me up here if you
see a funny young comedian on stage and
you say hey you're really funny you got
a lot of talent but then that comedian
follows you around and keeps trying out
their material on you
the worst thing you can do off stage is
running bits and this movie after a
while
and and it gets worse as a new character
like a tuturo shows up it feels like
this movie is running bits by you when
all i want to do is look at the
transformers and watch them fight you
know what as somebody that loves the
joke and will never and will kill it i i
think that's why this is my movie if i
like a joke tell it again i'm sorking in
that way it was a great line once
you can use it again later i am very
aaron sorkin in that and i will just let
you guys sort of you know have your
moment as the only woman on this uh chat
this morning too about the transformers
i was surprised thank you shout out to
mark hoffmeyer for this information to
learn that you know on top of you know
the franchise grossing billions at the
box office apparently there was female
transformers and i guess they cut her to
avoid the smurfette effect winston did
you know about this no i did not know
that they did that at all um
that's kind of whack
you know just let her get in there like
like honestly you could have made her
you could you could have put her on
either side i would have said put her on
the decepticon side and like let her be
the most vicious out of everybody like
because her name would have been equal
block nope don't do that
um
they wouldn't have done that they would
have done that on the autobots shaniqua
roll out
themselves and like incubate it it's
like it's like starfish style you cut
off half and then it becomes big also
here's another part
how do you make transformers the thing
was about the all spark right this
created all sentient life all the
transformers so the all spark runs loose
in the city what you suppose runs loose
in the city and it's just hitting
vending machines and everything but
every robot it creates is a decepticon
that was one thing that one's instantly
angry
every robot is instantly angry
a vending machine no i think it was
angry based on what it was like a
vending machine they just get pushed
give it to me like a vending machine is
very transactional it's probably tired
like i would i feel like the vending
machine was like why don't they just ask
me how my day is going they just shove
money in there and asked me to give them
things
sounds like another type of transaction
that don't sound like a vending machine
it just sounds like something completely
but i can see in that point i could see
how the soda machine would be a little
fed up and the minute it gets to start
moving
oh wait a minute come on now you don't
make you don't turn the nokia phone into
this little death robot you don't turn
an xbox into a death robot like none of
them are like like as if you guys don't
abuse your xbox please i do not my xbox
and i just chill a lot like i'm
surprised that the xbox didn't wake up
and go bro let's go get some taco bell
and chill
like i was i was like concerned that
every single human piece of technology
instantly wanted to murder us on top of
the fact that i heard the trans uh not
the transformers the uh terminator theme
multiple times just kind of sneak into
the da da da da and i was like so dude
we're just this is this is what we're
doing now right we're just this th this
is skynet coming to life because of the
all sparks also when you talk about how
they murdered that nokia too they knew
they knew the phone was just trying to
live its life he was like hey man i'm
just following orders and they killed
him they microwaved him i know that was
a shame movie
starts to spin out of control at the at
the climactic battle but there is a lot
of great action at least that you get
away from some of the comedy by the end
of this and so like i think the
redeeming value of this first
transformers movie is that i will say it
is by far the best in the entire
franchise until
we got to bumblebee yeah because about
to say yeah before we get out of here we
have to give bumblebee a little bit of
love yeah it's a it's a good movie but
the first like eight minutes of
bumblebee that take place like at the
transformers
home planet mm-hmm
that is something special that is
awesome that's the entire movie that i
want to see yeah is it uh travis scott
yeah trump scott did that one yeah i
know really incredible um
it shows too that that uh director the
one thing i want to talk about it said
how much not only did he love
transformers he loved the movies and he
wanted to make et with transformers
which is some of the vibe like basically
transformers works when you make it into
et with your transformers which is what
bumblebee is when you try to make it
into bad boys
with transformers which is what this
first one is that's where things get i
think a little bit whatever it has to go
back to that child like nostalgia like
whatever and so if you wanted to sort of
put the skin of transformers over any
sort of kid-like movie
that's the way to go
but uh i don't know necessarily if uh
that was what they were going for on
this one because it does feel a little
bit adult but yeah i mean the the best
thing that came out of
this initial transformers movie honestly
is the lincoln park song what i've done
like if we're just being a thousand
percent real
you threw it in at the end as well to
let us know starscream is going to get
back up you know or to take over the
decepticons like you know you're sitting
here kind of belting it why optimus is
sultry voice the autobots will remain on
our new planet earth thank you like i
mean it was it was
that that was the best part of the film
was the ending first also optimus is a
freeloader if we've really been really
thinking about it because at the end of
the movie octopus was like hey yo i
found a new place to kick it
and ladies and gentlemen that's how
black people are actually gonna change
stuff because really that's all it takes
just get one of us in the room we're
gonna sneak in all of our cousins and
i'm sorry but you've been warned
come on come on
thank you winston and jay it's been
really fun to chat with y'all today
thank you for having me for having me at
least
[Laughter]
the uncle that just stays and will not
leave the ox cable
midnight midnight one o'clock just it's
all about him for the hitting on your
cousin talking about you don't feel that
real nostril like that
i do thank you very much jacqueline and
mark for having us once again uh us
jay uh but but yeah you know thank you
for having the both of us we appreciate
you all
i feel like jay's a decepticon and
winston is the autobot of this
relationship is that accurate
i would feel like bumblebee because i
feel like if i don't talk in references
that jay's just going to ignore me
i'm sorry that hurt really
[Laughter]
shade is so good that you just are like
yeah i gotta take that l
just give me that finger like yeah you
you got that from certain you get that
jay where can folks find you anything
you want to let them know about sure
twitter and instagram and mr j
washington mrjy you should know how to
spell washington the mad titan podcast i
do by myself uh
you can
oh i talk about all the marvel and dc
live-action tv shows and movies and
blurbs in the hood that i do with this
certain person uh every tuesday and
thursday 6 p.m pacific 9 pm eastern we
are for the month of february
exclusively on twitch twitch.tv slash
blurt in the hood but our normal youtube
channel is youtube.com blurts in the
hood and um yeah i got a bunch of
stand-up shows coming up in and around
los angeles outside of la and all that
so they'll all be on my social media all
right mr winston hey marshall sir what
you got yeah you can find me anywhere
that swaggy blurs are sold twitter
instagram facebook youtube all that good
stuff uh monday wednesday and friday
around the 10 a.m area uh i'm on twitch
uh we kind of use that time not only to
play games but to you know set your
inspirations for the week your
motivations all that good stuff we check
in throughout the week while also kind
of talking about stuff that's going on
in
the world uh obviously blurts in the
hood as jay mentioned and other than
that i believe
that's pretty much it but but please you
know follow uh blurts in the hood on
twitter instagram twitch youtube all
that stuff thank you to our dear friends
uh winston marshall jay washington shout
out to peter cullen the great voice of
optimus prime and kevin dunn who is the
dad of uh sam witwitke who is great in
hotshots and i see him at the dog park
that molly goes to sometimes oh that's
super sweet i guess that's i guess
that's maybe my dog park too anyway
that's it for us this week we will see
you guys next week on rotten tomatoes is
wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you